une question d'une personne non nous
n'avons que les initiales fb d'où vient
l'expression casser du sucre sur le dos
cassé du sucre sur le dos de quelqu'un
n'a rien d'une petite douceur cette
expression apparue au 19e siècle
signifie dire du mal de quelqu'un en son
absence pour comprendre l'idée de sur le
dos mais pourquoi ils cassent pont du
sucre c'est un peu un mystère on peut
quand même se rappeler qu'au xviiie
siècle le sucre n'arrivait pas en poudre
sur la table mais en tant qu il fallait
briser en petits morceaux casser du
sucre et est donc synonyme d'activités
ingrate et ennuyeuse par ailleurs le
sucre à l'époque n'était déjà pas
toujours associé à la gentillesse dès le
xviie siècle l'expression se sucraient
de quelqu'un voulait dire le prendre
pour un imbécile
l'expression actuelle est peut-être
issus de ses diverses origines et en
tout cas elle laisse un goût amer